mondiale ilan ont doublement célèbre il
est en train de se faire un prénom
matthieu chedid fils du chanteur louis
et petit fils d'andré la romancière
mathieu donc que certains appellent tout
simplement m vient de sortir son
deuxième album un album qu'il teste en
tournée dans toute la france olivier les
nous a aidé yann richard l'ont rencontré
du côté de perpignan m le maudit le
verbe aimer
je dis stop
sûrement
jeudi m une chanson écrite par la grand
mère de mathieu l'écrivain andrée chedid
une grand mère un petit fils ben on peut
aussi être sur la même longueur d'onde
parler la même langue et puis arrivé à
confronter nos cultures et nos
générations et en faire quelque chose et
que je pense que j'ai la chance d'avoir
une grand-mère très ouverte et très
jeune et qui écrit bien oui
n comme monde un univers onirique et
enfantin quand je l'appelle mathieu et
on va juste chanter un ou deux morceaux
comme ça pour se mettre dans pour donner
envie de faire de la musique comme fait
déjà de la musique des instruments c'est
juste du sauvetage
quand j'étais petit j'ai été baigné dans
la musique donc dans un milieu comme ça
onirik parce qu'il ya du rêve là dedans
il ya de la musique il ya des gens des
rencontres des choses assez incroyables
donc peut-être que c'est à travers aussi
cette enfance musical que j'ai envie de
la retrouver dans le regard des autres
est dans le regard des enfants 16
matches
auteur compositeur et interprète
matthieu chedid a collaboré à des
qualités m jane birkin
vanessa paradis je vois leo ferré joie
gainsbourg jacques brel boris vian voilà
donc c'est à dire que a priori ce qui
m'apprennent le plus pour l'instant
mes références sont des gens d'une autre
époque parce que la qualité de perdurer
la qualit être trans perd tout le reste
oda la flemmardise tranquille jamais
déguise un loukoum géant sur un tapis
volant au volant d'un tapis blanc
à 27 ans aime promène ses mots avec
aisance et légèreté
ces mots ciselés par la fantaisie de
l'âme d'un artisan chanteur
voilà